so I'm a professional poker player and
today I want to talk about three things
that the game have taught me around
decision-making that I find apply to
everyday life now the first of these
things is about luck now like poker life
is also a game of skill and luck and
when it comes to the biggest things we
care about health wealth and
relationships these outcomes don't only
depend on the quality of our
decision-making but also the role of
life's dice for example we can be
perfectly health conscious and still get
unlucky with something like cancer or we
can smoke 20 a day and live to a ripe
old age and this kind of ambiguity can
make it hard for us to know how good our
strategies are sometimes especially when
we're experiencing a lot of success for
example back in 2010 I won a really big
poker tournament known as the European
Poker Tour and because I'd only been
playing full-time for about a year when
I won I assumed I must be rather
brilliant in fact I thought I was so
brilliant that I not only got rather
lazy with studying the game I also got
more risky started playing in the
biggest tournaments I could against the
very best in the world and then my
profit graph went from a thing of beauty
to something kind of sad with this
whirring downhill trend for a long time
until I finally realized that I was
overestimating my skill level and got my
act together and this kind of reminds me
of what we've been seeing in the
cryptocurrency space at least in 2017
where the only thing that's been going
up faster than the markets themselves
with a number of senior investment
specialists who have been appearing out
of nowhere now I'm not saying it's not
possible to have a strategic edge but at
the same time it's very easy to feel
like a genius when you're in a market
that's going up so fast that even the
worst strategies are making a profit so
when we're experiencing success it's
it's important to take a moment to
really ask ourselves how much of it is
truly down to us because our egos love
to downplay the luck factor when we're
winning
our second thing poco taught me is the
importance of quantifying my thinking
when you're playing you can't just get
away with going ah they're probably
bluffing that's just going to lose you a
bunch of money because poker is a game
of probabilities and precision and so
you have to train yourself to think in
numbers so now whenever I catch myself
thinking vaguely about something really
important like it's unlikely I'll forget
what I want to say in my TED talk I now
try to estimate it numerically trust me
it helps a lot with the planning process
and the thing is almost anything that
could possibly happen here today or at
any point in the future can also be
expressed as a probability - so now I
also try to speak in numbers as well so
if someone else meets hey Liv do you
think you're gonna come along to that
thing tonight instead of just saying to
them yeah probably I actually given my
best estimate say 60% because I know it
sounds a little odds but the thing is I
ran a poll on Twitter of what people
understand the word probably to mean and
this was the spread of answers enormous
so apparently it's absolutely useless or
actually conveying any real information
so if you guys catch yourselves using
these vague words like probably or
sometimes try instead using numbers
because when we speak in numbers we know
what lands in the other person's brain
now the third thing I want to touch on
today is intuition how often have you
seen these kind of inspirational memes
in your Facebook feed they're nice right
it's lovely
yes trust your soul well they're
terrible advice these are some of the
best poker players in the world right
now so they look like people who live
purely off feelings and intuitions look
at them obviously these guys are about
slow careful analysis and that's because
the game has outgrown the days where
pure street smarts and and in people
reading can get you to the top and
that's because
our intuitions aren't nearly as perfect
as we'd like to believe I mean it'd be
great whenever we're in a tough spot to
just have an answer appear to us from
some magical source of inspiration but
in reality our gut is extremely
vulnerable to all kinds of wishful
thinking and biases so then what is our
gut good for well all the studies I've
read conclude that it's best suited for
everyday things that we have lots and
lots of experience in like how we just
know that our friend is mad at us before
we've even said anything to them or
whether we can fit our car into a tight
parking spot but when it comes to the
really big stuff like what's our career
path going to be or who should we marry
there's why should we assume that our
intuitions are better calibrated for
these than slow proper analysis I mean
they don't have any data to be based off
so my third lesson is while we shouldn't
ignore our intuitions we shouldn't over
privileged them either and I'd like to
summarize these three lessons today with
my own set of memes with with more of a
poker player twist success is sweetest
when you achieve it across a large
sample size your gut is your friend and
so is a cost-benefit analysis the future
is unknown but you can damn well try and
estimate it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]